[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis lundi elle était portée disparue
en mayenne une joggeuse portée disparue
cette disparition d'une adolescente elle
est partie courir près de chez elle et
n'est jamais revenu amir est la joggeuse
de 17 ans était retrouvé 24 heures après
dans un restaurant à une dizaine de
kilomètres de chez elle l'excellente
nouvelle tombée hier la joggeuse de 17
ans réussit à échapper à son ou ses
ravisseurs ensanglanté toujours en tenue
de jogging la jeune fille qui aurait
réussi à échapper à ses ravisseurs
étaient en état de choc elle a été
immédiatement prise en charge par des
médecins si ses proches sont soulagés
les criminels courent toujours il
pourrait faire d'autres victimes la
priorité c'est de retrouver le ou les
ravisseurs une enquête a été ouverte
pour enlèvement et séquestration ce soir
nous recevons guven le patron du
restaurant qui a recueilli la jeune
fille il va nous raconter ce qui s'est
réellement passé
whissell et su éviter pour touche pas à
mon poste 19h48 on est en direct et on a
bu revêt buvén duval inquiète avec no
mercy guven
bonsoir et merci d'être là guven parce
que c'est vrai que je sais que il ya
énormément du journaliste énormément de
gens devant votre restaurant qui
souhaite vous parler et merci de nous
parler par visio ce soir et nous
raconter cette affaire qui est assez
folle merci beaucoup qui viennent
merci à lui donner la parole que toi
alors nouvel e donc vous êtes dans votre
restaurant vous êtes le gérant du kebab
où la jeune fille a trouvé refuge hier
soir après avoir échappé à son ses
ravisseurs vous faisiez quoi comment où
la jeune fille est arrivée il était
quelle heure environ
il était un peu plus de 20 heures 8h08
heure 10 environ
j'étais avec un client j'étais en train
de prendre la commande d'un client une
routine avec un client je les prenais ça
comment là elle rentre dans le kebab
est-ce que vous avez tout de suite
compris qui s'était dans quel état lité
ce qui se passait ou pas du tout
en fait il y avait deux clients qui est
deux trois clients qui étaient devant
donc lcl est arrivé au niveau de la
vitrine elle s'est posée elle a posé sa
main contre la vitrine
elle a dit à une des clientes je suppose
que c'était elle est en fait moi c'est
une cliente qui m'a dit elle est rentrée
dans la boutique en me disant
c'est la jeune fille qui est disparu la
veille donc c'est la jeune fille qui a
disparu et si vous avez entendu parler
de ça va faire un site ou dans la dans
la boutique ça fait entendu parler de
cette affaire mais
oui oui dans les journaux enfin on
allait les journaux locaux ici il en
avait parlé dès lundi soir elle est
arrivée en quête d'un call it à cette
jeune fille
elle était été choqué quand même elle
était ensanglanté elle
[Musique]
et elle était choquée d'accord il ya des
choses que je vais pas renvoyer pas
dévoilés pour la suite de l'enquêté ça
alors là on vous voit en pause mais vous
êtes on vous devine derrière vous
inquiétez pas aiguë vaines qu'est ce
qu'elle vous a dit cette jeune fille
l'âge j'ai pas grand chose en fait j ai
demandé son nom
si elle avait mal quelque part et puis
ça c'est ça s'est arrêté là vous avez
appelé la police station des gets appelé
aussi tout la gendarmerie j'ai été en
ligne avec la gendarmerie quand on l'a
recueilli on a on l'a mis à l'intérieur
du restaurant et j'étais avec la
gendarmerie de téléphone et donc du coup
j'ai pas j'ai pas cherché à discuter non
plus pas d'accord vous avez essayé de
lui parler de la rassurer de deux voies
la passe comme a été très choqué
on a installé derrière je le donnais
chine et donner un gilet passé elle
avait froid et puis et puis voilà après
après moi j'étais au téléphone avec la
gendarmerie donc j'ai pas tu me suis pas
attardé très bien aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que dans un signe c'est une histoire qui
finit bien c'est un c'est un truc de fou
un minerai cette affaire un gilles vous
avez des infos oui ce qui est très
étonnant c'est que visiblement elle se
serait enfui d'un véhicule avec des
hommes à bord un ou deux ravisseurs qui
sont recherchés il ya une enquête pour
enlèvement et séquestration
donc peut-être demander à monsieur ou
savoir s'il a vu cette camionnette ou
alors pour l'instant je pense qu'il peut
par hip hop guven je pense que vous
pouvez rien dire pour l'instant vous
avez été entendu par la police
j'ai été entendu par la police où il a
été auditionné pendant pendant quelques
heures oui j'ai discuté avec la police
on peut rien dire de toute façon c'est
pas grand chose mais voilà
le cadre elle est là on a on a été
entendu pendant trois heures environ et
voilà la pub n je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui veulent vous parler
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je vous
le dis gouvernent aujourd'hui peut dire
très peu de choses parce que par rapport
à l'an qué tu peux pas prendre de risque
guyenne et de remettre de nous donner
des éléments qui pourraient faire que l'
enquête soit paralysée au foie ralentit
donc forcément goût vanille peu très peu
parlé aujourd'hui la jeune fille juste
qu'on voudrait savoir l aile et elle va
mieux vous avez pris de ses nouvelles
j'ai plus élevés non d'accord mais c'est
pas du tout d'accord très bien en tout
cas merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
guven et je sais qu'il ya plein de gens
qui vous attendent devant votre
restaurant tout cas bravo parce que
c'est grâce à lui on n'en est rien que
l'alerté a été donnée qu'elle a pu être
prise par les gendarmes merci bravo à
vous qui viennent en tout cas merci
j'avais juste nettoyées et j'avais juste
une petite chose
je vais en profiter pour établir aussi
une vérité alice vis-à-vis des médias
ouais moi c'est la première fois que je
parle aujourd'hui de la faire et il ya
eu des choses qui ont été dites dans
certains médias comme quoi ça venait de
ma part qui sont complètement fausses le
voilà je voulais tenir à rétablir la
vérité à aucun moment et j'ai parlé à
personne vous êtes les seuls vraiment à
qui je parle en premier très bien parce
que les prévisions étaient il ya des
fausses infos qui ont été colportées et
qu'on est des gens ont dit que c'était
cubaine la cave est donné c'est un faux
lui salles met énormément en porte à
faux par rapport à l'enquêté par rapport
à la gendarmerie à la police donc voilà
guven s'était bien qu'ils fassent ce
petit cette petite mise au point pour
dire que voilà c'est la première fois
qu'ils parlent aux médias et c'est vrai
qu'il reste voyez il peut pas en dire
plus sains du gène voilà parce que c'est
extrêmement compliqué pour lui il peut
pas non plus mettre en danger la suite
de l' enquête